[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend 20
minuten sortieren wir wieder die
wichtigsten nachrichten für sie goldige
von den olympischen spielen katja
gehören auch wieder dazu und es sind
weder die flaschen guten abend unser
themen überblick
manöver nahe der ukrainischen grenze
eine russische militärübung in belarus
überschattet internationale
vermittlungsversuche
höhere hürden für pcr tests kostenlos
soll es sie künftig nur nach einem
positiven schnelltest geben um die
labore zu entlasten
und die berlinale beginnt unter chor
ohne auflagen aber mit rotem teppich und
publikum werden die internationalen
filmfestspiele eröffnet
in london paris und brüssel wurde heute
noch einmal davor gewarnt wie gefährlich
die situation an der ukrainischen grenze
ist in diesen minuten versucht man in
berlin wieder eine diplomatische lösung
zu finden dazu gleich mehr zunächst der
blick in den osten wo die bedrohung
spürbarer wird moskau hält ein xxl
militärmanöver in und mit belarus ab die
abwehr äußerer aggression soll trainiert
werden heißt es von russischer seite auf
5 truppenübungsplätzen und vier
luftwaffenstützpunkten viele unweit der
polnischen grenze und auch in der nähe
der ukraine tausende soldaten und
schweres militärgerät wurden verlegt
aber russland beruhigt nur eine übung
keine bedrohung der westen das wissen
sie sieht es ganz anders axel sturm
bilder wie aus einem werbefilm
inszeniert vom russischen
verteidigungsministerium russische jets
im himmel über belarus am boden gefechts
übungen drohkulisse und kein ende kein
ende auch bei den mahnungen im westen
wir beobachten die russischen kräfte in
belarus sehr genau es ist die grösste
truppen ansammlung seit ende des kalten
krieges dies ist ein gefährlicher moment
für die europäische sicherheit
die nato sagte russland habe inzwischen
rund 30.000 soldaten nach belarus
geschickt russland kommentiert das nicht
verspricht aber die einhaltung
internationale absprachen die soldaten
würden nach dem manöver zurückkehren
auch aus kiew kommend kritische töne
das einzige land dass die spannungen zu
see und auf dem land verschärft ist
russland
die lage bleibt angespannt trotz vieler
hochkarätiger diplomatische gespräche
heute in moskau die britische
außenministerin man fand offenbar nicht
zusammen ihr gastgeber vergleicht das
gespräch wie das zwischen einem tauben
und einem stummen menschen
ich kann keinen anderen grund für die
stationierung von 100.000 soldaten an
der ukrainischen grenze erkennen als
eine bedrohung wenn russland ernsthaft
an diplomat ihn interessiert ist dann
müssen diese truppen abgezogen und die
bedrohung unterlassen werden
auch die armee der ukraine trainiert
heute blizzard als die übung im süden
bei person
ja und an der ukrainischen grenze zu
velaros da ist christian senn christian
wie angespannt ist es wie geht die
bevölkerung mit der situation um
ja ich stehe an einem ukrainischen
grenzposten an der grenze zu belarus der
ist offiziell wegen co wird geschlossen
wir mussten ja auch ein paar meter
weiter nach vorne gehen können nicht
direkt dort stehen weil man die andere
seite die belarussische seite nicht
provozieren will wir uns die
grenzsoldaten erklärt haben wir mit
einigen menschen hier im dorf gesprochen
in den letzten tagen und die stimmung
ist da doch sehr unterschiedlich die
einen machen sich natürlich sorgen weil
man dieses ganze manöver auch nicht
wirklich greifen kann und die menschen
wissen auch nicht was passiert was
wladimir putin will diese frage stellen
sich ja viele andere gehen ganz anders
und mit der frage und sind fast schon
empört und sagen was soll der quatsch
dieses gerede vom krieg nie im leben
wird es hier krieg gehen geben wir haben
unterschiedliche familiäre bindungen
nach belarus nach russland wenn man die
menschen hier hört es wird ukrainisch
gesprochen es wird bilder russisch
gesprochen es wird russisch gesprochen
und da sagen die menschen hier neben
leben wird es krieg geben geben wir
werden noch nicht untereinander
aufeinander schießen und uns gegenseitig
den krieg erklären und dann gibt es
wieder andere wie sehen es doch eher
fast fatalistisch die sagen naja wenn
die russen kommen wir können nichts
machen wir wohnen hier wir können nicht
weg und da müssen wir irgendwie damit
klarkommen danke für die eindrücke
christiansen nicht nur die ukrainische
regierung fühlt sich massiv bedroht von
russland sondern auch die von estland
lettland und litauen über ihre konkreten
forderungen an deutschland sprachen die
baltischen staatsspitzen heute mit dem
kanzler in berlin parallel dazu gab es
auch wieder eine fortsetzung des
normandie formates in der hauptstadt
also gespräche auch berater ebene
zwischen russland der ukraine frankreich
und deutschland mehr von lars boden sank
eigentlich ist es ein positives zeichen
im gästehaus des auswärtigen amtes
sitzen abgeschirmt von der
öffentlichkeit die konfliktparteien
russland und ukraine an einem tisch
deutschland und frankreich versuchen
dabei zu vermitteln weniger positiv
klingt die unterschwellige drohung des
russischen botschafters in berlin wenn
die ukraine mit waffen truppen und
sondereinheiten aus dem ausland folge
rom wird kann das auch zur provokationen
führen in dieser weiter angespannten
situation empfängt kanzler olaf scholz
die chefs der baltischen staaten
die treten für einen harten kurs
gegenüber moskau ein
unser bündnis muss in der lage sein
rasch zu reagieren und entschlossen zu
reagieren
die bereitschaft der nato in der region
ist ein wichtiges abschreckungs
instrument es ist von entscheidender
bedeutung wie wir die östliche flanke
der nato stärken
auf
island will 9 artilleriegeschütze in die
ukraine liefern die noch aus ddr
beständen stammen die bundesregierung
aber lehnt weiter die lieferung
tödlicher waffen ab dennoch in dieser
für uns alle kritischen situation sollte
russland unsere einigkeit und
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen als
partner in der eu und das verbündete in
der nato ich möchte klar sagen wir
nehmen die sorgen unserer verbündeten
sehr ernst waffenlieferungen bleiben
also umstritten in der nato die
krisendiplomatie läuft weiter auf
hochtouren
ja wir fragen nach bei theo koll in
berlin theo frankreichs präsident der
britische premier oder der nato-chef die
waren ja noch mal davor wie gefährlich
der aktuelle situation ist wo steht die
diplomatie
nun der russische außenminister hat die
lage heute relativ treffend beschrieben
er sagte es ist als ob wir zu hören aber
nichts verstehen die diplomatie gibt
sich alle mühe und macht überstunden und
gleichzeitig veranstalten beide seiten
wir haben gerade gesehen russland und
ukraine militärische manöver
zeigen ihre muskeln und nähmen in kauf
dass die lage immer gefährlicher wird
die bundesregierung lehnt weiterhin
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine ab das
dürfte auch bleibend für die ddr
haubitzen gelten die die esten ja nur
mit deutscher genehmigung liefern dürfen
das gefällt den balten nicht aber sie
lösen das thema anders lizenz
regierungschefin hat heute angekündigt
schon in den nächsten tagen
flugabwehrraketen in die ukraine zu
liefern und die stammen aus
amerikanischer produktion die politische
verantwortung auf allen seiten könnte
kaum größer sein kanzlei stolz meinte
eben
es geht um nicht weniger als krieg in
europa zu verhindern und nur zur
erinnerung kiew ist kaum weiter von
berlin entfernt als paris es bleibt
extrem angespannt danke theo koll nach
berlin jetzt zur corona pandemie
inzwischen haben 55 prozent der menschen
in deutschland eine booster impfung
bekommt das meldet das
robert-koch-institut bei den fallzahlen
registrierte das lka
247 1862 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 11 1742 mehr als vor
einer woche
238 todesfälle kamen hinzu und die
sieben tage incident steigt auf 1400
65,4 weil labore und gesundheitsämter an
der kapazitätsgrenze arbeiten sind die
zahlen aber wohl unvollständig
also wieder zahlen hoch wie nie in
deutschland und das bedeutet natürlich
entsprechend sehr viel mehr pcr
testungen deshalb sollen sich jetzt die
test regeln ändern was wann im
infektionsfall gilt und wie man konkret
vorgeht dazu herrscht aktuell große
verunsicherung und alles was sie wissen
müssen jetzt von alexandra vacano die
korona waren app immer häufiger leuchtet
sie bei vielen rot vor kurzem konnte man
damit noch einen kostenfreien pcr test
bekommen jetzt nicht mehr laut entwurf
der neuen corona virus test verordnung
wer kann künftig pcr tests machen zuerst
mal risikogruppen menschen in der pflege
oder im medizinischen bereich ihre pcr
tests haben vorrang im labor damit die
betroffenen sicherheit haben
grundsätzlich aber können alle weiterhin
auf kostenlosen pcr test bestehen auch
kinder unter bestimmten bedingungen so
soll es für alle ablaufen hat man einen
positiven selbst test muss der erst
gegen gecheckt werden mit einem antigen
schnell test in einem zertifizierten
testzentrum ist der positiv kann ein pcr
test in anspruch genommen werden um
gewissheit zu bekommen und was es mit
frei testen wenn man als infizierter
seine isolierung oder als kontaktperson
seine quarantäne vorzeitig beenden will
hier muss künftig nur noch ein
offizieller antigen schnelltest gemacht
werden
nahost reisen sind für deutsch
diplomaten immer ein besonderer
balance-akt somit auch für deutschlands
neue außenministerin annalena baerbock
die drei tage die region bereist zum
auftakt heute bewegende momente in der
holocaust gedenkstätte jad vaschem aus
israel michael bewerunge
der besuch der holocaust gedenkstätte
jad vaschem ist pflichtprogramm für
jeden staatsgast in israel doch gerade
für die aus deutschland wird er nie zum
ritual
wie etwa chef gibt den millionen juden
die von deutschen ermordet wurden eine
geschichte ein gesicht als mutter zweier
töchter sagt annalena baerbock habe hier
immer wieder der atem gestockt der
gedanke an den schmerz jedes einzelnen
kindes
jeder einzelne mutter jedes einzelnen
vaters es kaum zu ertragen
der besuch der neuen außenministerin
wird in israel kritisch beäugt steht sie
als politikerin einer neuen generation
ebenso vorbehaltslos zur sicherheit
israels baerbock lässt keine zweifel
daran und setzt doch klare akzente auch
diese bundesregierung ist davon
überzeugt dass die verhandelte
zwei-staaten-lösung noch immer die beste
option für frieden und sicherheit von
israelis und palästinensern
gleichermaßen ist wir haben deswegen zum
siedlungsbau eine eindeutige haltung wir
halten ihn für schädlich und mit dem
völkerrecht nicht vereinbar nur grüne
wir israel wird nichts bauen was die
möglichkeit einer zwei staaten lösung
verhindert antwortet rapid ansonsten
stimmen wir überein hier nicht
übereinzustimmen wir gratulieren
letzteres trifft besonders auf
ministerpräsident bennett zu dennoch
nicht mal mit den palästinensern reden
will baerbock aber will und hat am abend
auch palästinenserpräsident mahmud abbas
in ramallah getroffen
ein rechtsextremist in richterrobe in
sachsen ist das tatsächlich eine
aktuelle frage es geht um den fdp
politiker und richter jens maier er
zählt zum völkischen flügel der partei
und hatte den wiedereinzug in den
bundestag verpasst jetzt will der 60
jährige von seinem rückkehr nicht
gebrauch machen und wieder in der
sächsischen justiz arbeiten das sei
unerträglich sagen jetzt juristen
bundesweit aus dresden cornelia
schiemenz
jens meyer bezeichnete sich selbst als
kleinen hütte und wird vom sächsischen
verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft trotzdem möchte er nun wieder
zurück auf die richterbank denn das
abgeordnetengesetz gibt parlamentariern
ein rückkehrrecht und von dem will meyer
gebrauch machen für die sächsische
justiz ministerin katja meier schwierig
zu verhindern sie habe keine handhabe so
sagt sie ich kann und werde nicht
riskieren dass ein disziplinarverfahren
am ende vor dem gericht keinen bestand
hat nur weil es diesen politischen druck
gibt die justiz ministerin würde den
ball gerne weiterspielen in den
sächsischen landtag hier prüfen linke
und grüne gerade die möglichkeit einer
richter anklage die bräuchte aber eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und die regierende
cdu lehnt ab er kehrt vom bundestag
zurück hat keine arbeit will wieder
zurück stellt den antrag dann ist die
dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde sprich das
justizministerium zuständig und da kann
das justizministerium sagen komm zu mir
in die behörde und dann arbeitest du bei
mir und dann ist ja kein richter am
richter am landgericht und damit ist die
sache erledigt ob es wirklich so einfach
ist seit wochen grübeln juristen über
die causa jens maier inzwischen sorgt
der fall für bundesweite empörung es
wäre fatal wenn in deutschland jemand
recht sprechen dürfte der sich mehrfach
verfassungsfeindlich geäußert hat und
wir haben ein großes problem dann mit
der akzeptanz der justiz in der
bevölkerung jens maier selbst will sich
nicht äußern er wartet ab bis 15 märz
muss ihm der freistaat sachsen eine
stelle zugewiesen haben
corona ist für sehr viele in der
kulturbranche so etwas wie ein
katastrophenfilm ohne ende und darum ist
es auch ein zeichen der hoffnung dass
heute abend die berlinale eröffnet wird
unter strengen coroner bedingungen zwar
aber in präsenz mit stars mit
weltpremieren und fast allem was dazu
gehört stephan merseburger ist für uns
dabei
ein hauch von normalität schaulaufen auf
dem roten teppich die 72 berlinale
findet anders als im letzten jahr als
präsenzveranstaltung stadt abgespeckt
ohne hollywood stars partys und empfänge
aber das kino lebt und feiert sich trotz
corona
sehr gutes gefühl und ich glaube ist
eine richtige entscheidung wenn ist ja
nur
im tunnel die ganze zeit und es ist mal
kurz
mal kurz über den teppich mal kurz sich
treffen sicherheit wird großgeschrieben
zweig plus auch gepostete fachbesucher
brauchen täglich einen anti gen test
halbe belegung der kinosäle sechs statt
der üblichen zehn festivaltage
aus frankreich das im wettbewerb diesmal
stark vertreten ist kommt auch der
eröffnungsfilm von francoise
peter von kannte erzählt von liebe macht
und machtmissbrauch ein schwuler
filmregisseur verguckt sich in einem
blutjungen schauspieler der film ist ein
remake eines fassbinder film
für mich ist fast wieder so etwas wie
ein großer bruder ich habe seine filme
als student entdeckt sie haben mich sehr
berührt und ich fand sie sowohl
ästhetisch als auch politisch
interessant wie die politik rainer
werner fassbinders die bitteren tränen
der petra kant erzählt die geschichte
als lesbische liebe und ist dabei
trotzdem autobiografisch die große hanna
schygulla ist in beiden versionen zu
sehen
nach berlin kommt die 78 jährige nicht
aus angst vor carola
ja mensch hat ja immer wenn ich zum
sport übergeben es mir schon fast
unheimlich sag ich immer das gleiche
wieder eine goldmedaille für deutschland
täglich grüßt das deutsche rodel-team
vierte entscheidung im rennrodeln
viertes mal gold für deutschland aber
dieses mal im teamwettbewerb haben es
natalie geisenberger johannes ludwig und
das duo wendl/arlt
unfassbar spannend gemacht
tobias wendl und tobias arlt fahren
bahnrekord und sicher nimmt doppelsitzer
damit der deutschen team staffel gold in
einem sehr spannenden knappen rennen
zuvor waren natalie geisenberger und
johannes ludwig den österreicher noch
hinterher erst während des laufs der
beiden berchtesgadener springt die zeit
auf grün und bleibt es bis zur
zieldurchfahrt alle olympischen
rodelwettbewerbe wieder gewonnen die
freude riesengroß
das ist kein selbstläufer wir sind oben
selbst immer ziemlich angespannt wir
wollen unser bestes geben sind natürlich
umso glücklicher wenn es am ende so
schön
aussieht vor österreich und lettland und
natalie geisenberger ist jetzt mit
sechsmal gold und einmal bronze
deutschlands erfolgreichste winter
olympionikin der historie
mit einer niederlage sind deutschlands
eishockey spieler ins olympische turnier
gestartet gegen kanada schoss das team
von toni so daheim ein tor kassierte
gleichzeitig allerdings fünf
frustrierende auftritt der deutschen
eishockey stars kann er da in allen
belangen überlegen und cleverer street
schlägt dem deutschen torwart den
schläger aus der hand so ist mathias
niederberger dann beim 1 0 durch plans
schuss stark benachteiligt der für
münchen spielende band street und daniel
wenig schießen nach zehn minuten schon
das 3 zu 0 für kanada heraus
nur noch für resultatkosmetik sorgte im
zweiten drittel tobias rieder aber die
kanadische offensive ist viel effektiver
als die deutsche
maxim noreau und jordan riehl sorgen
schließlich für einen unerwartet
deutlichen 5 1-sieg der nordamerikaner
jason chen wird mit sicherheit eines der
gesichter dieser spiele werden denn was
der us amerikaner in seiner eiskunstlauf
für aufs eis gezaubert hat ist einmalig
und brachte ihm das verdiente gold
es waren gleich fünf fast fehlerfreie
vierfach sprünge mit denen nächsten chen
zu olympischem gold fliegt zu elton
johns hit rocketman entthront der
dreimalige weltmeister aus den usa
überzeugend fast mühelos japans
superstar ihr zu radio und kreuz seine
medaille mit einer weltrekord bewertung
von
332,6 0 punkten
daher immer mein traum ein die auswahl
der musik habe zum sieg beigetragen
damit kann man doch einfach nur spaß
haben freut sich der 22 jährige nach
seinem triumph
und die gesamten vier minuten 30 kann
man in der zdf mediathek genießen so
voll wie sie auf
so und nach gold silber und bronze haben
wir jetzt noch einen diamanten den
größten schwarzen diamanten der welt
enigma heißt da wurde für 3,8 millionen
euro versteigert okay das teil sieht aus
wie ein geschliffenes und poliertes
brikett und um den hals hängen möchte
man sich sowas vielleicht auch nicht
aber der reiz liegt woanders den enigma
ist ein bote aus dem all wohl entstanden
als ein meteorit auf die erde fiel oder
ein schluckt man sagen ein galaktischer
klunker so oder so
so die sonne funkelt morgen auch aber
nur ein bisschen sonst regen und schnee
katja oliver hat gleich mehr das
heute-journal später mit christian
sievers um 21.45 wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen entspannten donnerstag schön dass
sie dabei waren und bis morgen um 19 uhr
[Musik]
guten abend von einem wintereinbruch zu
sprechen wäre immer noch verfehlt auch
wenn es jetzt vorübergehend mal von
norden etwas kälter wird und der regen
nicht nur auf den gipfeln in schnee
übergeht heute sagt machen sie sich also
bitte auf gefährlich glatte straßen
gefasst am ehesten trocken bleibt es in
norddeutschland die schneefallgrenze
liegt so etwa bei 500 meter und die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 4 bis minus
3 grad es kann also überall auf gehwegen
und straßen glatt sein und morgen ist es
deutlich kälter als zuletzt uns erwarten
höchsttemperaturen von zwei grad an den
alpen und in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen
sonst werden vier bis acht grad
erreichen dann rein wird es am mildesten
morgen vormittag schneit es noch am
längsten hier am alpenrand sonst sind
kräftige schauer unterwegs schnee regen
und graupelschauer vielleicht sind auch
mal kurze gewitter unterwegs und am
nachmittag lockern die wolken an der
nordseeküste dann besser auf am
alpenrand lässt der schneefall nach
sonst gibt es noch etliche schauer das
wird sich dann am samstag ändern da
scheint häufig die sonne bei
temperaturen von zwei bis acht grad am
sonntag wird es dann von nordwesten
schon wieder ein bisschen wechselhafter
da kommt auch regen an und es wird
wieder deutlich milder guten abend